monsieur lecanu et avant-hier vous nous
avez présenté votre plan de progrès
économique
de quoi allons nous entretenir
aujourd'hui et bien aujourd'hui nous
allons parler des problèmes sociaux
l'économique et le social sont
d'ailleurs deux questions étroitement
liés
on ne cherche à développer la production
économique que pour améliorer la
situation des hommes
au demeurant je constate que les lettres
qui me parviennent de plus en plus
nombreuse manifeste une préoccupation
essentielle du pays pour les problèmes
sociaux c'est-à-dire pour la vie de tous
les jours il ne s'agit pas à vous
l'imaginez bien pour moi de présenter un
catalogue de revendications sociales ce
que je veux c'est tenter avec vous de
prendre l'exacte mesure des étapes d'un
effort social que le pays doit consentir
il ne suffit pas d'un coeur qui
réclament des sous des sous et d'un chef
d'état qui répondent je n'en ai pas il
faut accélérer la progression de
l'économie est progressivement améliorer
la situation sociale des français
nous ne pouvons pas nous estimé
satisfait aussi longtemps que des
carences graves continuent d'affecter de
nombreuses régions et des catégories
sociales encore très défavorisé alors si
vous voulez bien nous allons regarder
l'ensemble de ces problèmes nous
pourrions prendre le cas d'une famille
française
le sujet mais familier c'est le cadre de
ma vie je suis né dans une famille très
modeste
mes parents dû faire des efforts pour me
permettre d'aller au bout de mes études
et moi même j'ai une famille avec trois
enfants qui ont comme on dit la juste
colère
et bien prenons une famille française
moyenne des milieux populaires
des classes moyennes examinons leurs
difficultés
elles sont multiples et pratiquement
elle se présente à chaque âge avec des
problèmes très ardue et très particulier
je les gagne elle moi je propose
d'adopter l'ordre chronologique puisque
nous suivons puisque vous suivez une
famille commençons par la jeunesse
c'est en effet un problème fondamental
il est très grave tout commence par
l'école combien d'entre vous qui avez
charge d'enfants est préoccupée par les
difficultés qu'ont ses enfants pour
prouver une école parfois éloignés s'ils
habitent à la campagne des enfants qui
fréquentent des classes trop souvent
surchargés
combien de familles ont du mal à trouver
une place pour leur enfant dans un
établissement technique ans vient l'âge
de la formation professionnelle combien
de familles voient à leur enfant écarté
du collège ou du lycée parce qu'il ne
réussit pas parfaitement ses études et
sont plongés dans la difficulté
combien de familles aussi ont des
enfants qui ne sont pas comme on dit
tout à fait comme les autres et qui
auraient besoin d'une formation
spécialisée
il faut donc un effort véritablement
énorme de l'état pour faire face à
toutes ses obligations
et pour cela il faut des crédits il faut
changer comme je l'expliquais avant-hier
les priorités dans notre budget le
gouvernement actuel ne fait pas un
effort suffisant
au début de la vème république il y a eu
une certaine progression des crédits de
l'éducation nationale maintenant nous
approchons d'une quasi stagnation si
l'on tient compte de l'augmentation des
prix de la construction des bâtiments
scolaires
il y à un chiffre devant lequel je veux
vous placez les chiffres ne mentent pas
le gouvernement tenant compte de la
progression du nombre des jeunes
c'est une progression connue les
rendez-vous sont certains ils sont
inéluctables avait chargé une commission
spéciale d'évaluer les crédits
nécessaires pour être présent au rendez
vous de la jeunesse
cette commission sur ordre du
gouvernement a fait ses comptes
elle a calculé qu'il fallait pour le
cinquième plan prévoir 32 milliards de
francs
savez vous combien le gouvernement on a
retenu dans le plan définitif
vincent c'est la démonstration que le
gouvernement parce qu'il ne dispose pas
d'assez crédit les utilisent pour des
dépenses contestable de prestige
n'arrive pas à réaliser les réformes
dont il sent cependant la nécessité
il n'y a pas que le problème des crédits
du niveau de vie des maîtres est
important de la construction des locaux
il ya le problème des études elle mène
des programmes
nous en sommes je crois au 7e ministre
de l'éducation nationale et on ne peut
pas dire que les changements soient tous
aller dans le sens de l'amélioration
nous allons de réforme en réforme
personne ne s'y retrouve pas même les
spécialistes de l'enseignement encore
moins les familles les jeunes les
étudiants
je crois que nous sommes fatigués de
réformes il faudrait là une certaine
stabilité ou pour mieux dire
on étudie pendant un an deux ans s'il le
faut une réforme qui serait définitive
et qu'elles ne viennent pas d'en haut
qu'elles soient concertés dialoguer avec
que les corps spécialisé de
l'enseignement les parents les familles
dans le respect des convictions de
chacun dans la liberté de ces familles
et avec les organismes représentatifs
des étudiants dans quel sens devrait
aller cette réforme je n'ai pas à la
préjugés mais il me semble qu'elle
devrait aller dans le sens d'un plus
grand rapprochement de la formation
intellectuelle professionnelle et de la
vie dans le sens d'un allègement des
programmes les concours
j'ai été moi-même jadis une bête à
concours je sais de quoi je parle
peuvent subsister les examens aussi mais
ils ne doivent pas devenir des butoirs
être la hantise de la jeunesse il faut
qu'à chaque étape
au lieu de l'élimination brutale il y
est l'orientation que l'on organise des
passerelles vers la formation technique
et professionnelle de façon que chaque
jeune garçon chaque fille centre elle
pourra servir à quelque chose dans la
vie et qu'elle a droit à tous son
épanouissement
il y a enfin un autre aspect grave pour
la jeunesse
c'est ce que nous appelons la nécessité
de démocratiser l'enseignement au cou
trop peu de fils de paysans dans les
collèges dans les lycées
trop peu de fils d'ouvriers dans les
facultés
c'est une atteinte à la dignité à la
justice
et c'est une erreur grave pour un pays
que de perdre ses investissements
intellectuelle il faut par conséquent
développer les bourses est probablement
plus tard aller jusqu'à l' allocation
d'études pour l'étudiant qui doit être
considérée comme un véritable travail r
ayants droit à sa rémunération
c'est là une justice fondamentale
n'arriveront peut-être jamais à faire
une société de totale égalité
il y à une sorte d'inégalité qui
tiennent à la vie' viande
bâtissons une cité juste humaine où
chaque enfant ou qu'il naisse quel que
soit son milieu et devant lui toutes les
chances égales et la possibilité de
donner à sa vie toute la dimension de
ses mérites et de son courage monsieur
je suppose problèmes résolus
je suppose que le jeune français a été
formé il est devenu adulte
premier problème pour lui le pain
quotidien c'est à dire le métier la
profession le travail vous posez là un
problème qui est celui de l'emploi
la france se rajeunit elle est plus
nombreuse
il faut donc multiplier les emplois j'ai
expliqué avant-hier comment l'animation
des régions l'industrialisation
l'accélération des investissements était
la condition de la création de ces
emplois nouveaux
le problème est beaucoup plus
préoccupant qu'il n'y paraît à première
vue
certes la france n'est pas un pays
malheureux mais nous avons tout de même
encore actuellement 150 mille chômeurs
auxquels s'ajoutent 150 mille jeunes qui
munis de certificats avoir de diplôme
n'ont pas leur entrée dans les
professions ça fait tout de même trois
cent mille personnes qui n'ont pas de
travail
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que le cinquième
plan qui va commencer au début de
l'année prochaine et qui a été établi
par l'actuel gouvernement envisage qu'il
pourrait y avoir un volant de 350 mille
chômeurs afin de donner ce qu'ils
appellent une certaine souplesse au
marché du travail gêne peut accepter une
telle perspective
nous devons réaliser le plein emploi car
il n'y a rien de plus affreux pour un
chef de famille que d'être privés du
droit de travailler il est grave aussi
que le cinquième plan du gouvernement ne
prévoit une sonnette d'alarmé ou comme
il dit des clignotants pour déclencher
des mesures
ur qui redonnerait du travail que s'il y
avait en france
cinq cent mille chômeurs je veux
absolument écarter cette manière de voir
qui est contraire aux aspirations du
pays et à sa jeunesse qui monte
il n'y a pas que le chômage total il y a
un certain chômage partiel et je ne vise
pas seulement les régions qui souffrent
d'un manque de développement c'est le
cas de la bretagne condamné un exode
dans les dix années qui viennent
depuis de 200000 des siens ce qui est
une injustice pour elle je ne parle pas
seulement de certaines régions du centre
songez qu'une région qui est l'une des
plus importantes traditionnellement dans
le domaine industriel comme la région du
nord est bien connaît dans plusieurs de
ces grandes entreprises
un chômage partiel beaucoup d'ouvriers
font moins de 40 heures songez aussi que
chaque jour dix sept mille alsaciens
sont obligés de traverser le rhin et
d'aller en allemagne pour trouver un
travail et le salaire qui leur convient
et cela en grande partie parce que le
gouvernement à empêcher l'installation
d' usine en alsace n'a pas favorisé
l'essor de l'alsace
tout ceci est donc grave mais parmi les
problèmes de l'emploi il en est un qui
présente une acuité but exceptionnel
c'est celui de l'agriculture
songez que le nombre d agriculteurs
représentent 20% de la population
française c'est un chiffre important
et bien c'est 20% ne reçoivent que 10%
du revenu national
chaque année cent mille agriculteurs
sont obligés de quitter la terre et
d'aller grossir
les rangs de ceux qui habitent les
grandes villes
songez que les revenus des agriculteurs
depuis deux ans ont diminué de 3%
voilà ce qui explique la gravité de la
situation agricole française je le
gagnais à votre aise à quoi cela tient
il est commun vous paraître est il
possible
à vous d'y rémédier il y à toute une
série de mesures à prendre pour arracher
l'agriculture française à ces
difficultés il ya d'abord le problème
des prix agricoles par le revenu de
l'agriculteur est fait de ses prix les
prix ont été privés par la vème
république de l'indexation
mais dans le même temps l'agriculteur
supporte toutes les hausses des produits
nécessaires à son exploitation et les os
de tout ce qu'il achète pour sa propre
vie
il ya ensuite le problème des structures
de l'agriculture qui ne peuvent se
mettre en mouvement que si les prix sont
rémunérateurs et les structures pour
évoluer pour permettre la modernisation
des groupements et de la
commercialisation des produits agricoles
suppose au préalable un très grand
effort d'équipement
or là encore comme pour l'éducation
nationale dont je parlais il ya un
instant nous constatons que le
gouvernement a réduit dans son budget de
l'année prochaine
les crédits d'équipement il devait être
de 2 milliards 6 à 1 milliard 6 il les a
réduits par rapport aux obligations peut
lui même estimé indispensable quand il a
élaboré le plan de développement des
cinq prochaines années
il ya aussi toutes les conditions
d'existence pour le monde agricole un
habitat généralement vétustes très
souvent plus que centenaire
des maisons privés de confort privé
encore très souvent de l'adduction d'eau
songez monsieur zitrone
il n'y a qu'une télévision pour huit
exploitations agricoles c'est un signe
de difficultés de vie quand on sait tout
l'intérêt que les français portent à la
possession d'un récepteur de télévision
bref les ruraux veulent à juste titre ce
qu'ils appellent la parité il la demande
et ce n'est que justice
les parlementaires ont essayer de
l'obtenir du gouvernement ils ont
demandé voici déjà bien des années à
être réunis en session spéciale le
pouvoir contrairement à la constitution
leur interdit de se réunir alors le
monde paysan qui est par définition le
monde de l' équilibre de la sagesse
s'est révolté nous avons eu les barrages
de routes
tant il est vrai que lorsque les
aspirations d'un pays ne peuvent pas
s'exprimer normalement par les
professions les syndicats et le
parlement
fatalement la révolte et la colère se
produisent et se manifestent les paysans
n'ont donc pas reçu la parité inscrit
tardivement dans la loire et qui ne se
réalisent pas dans les faits mais le
fond du problème agricole c'est le
marché comme le gouvernement lui-même
pendant des années a reconnu après
s'être converties à l'idée de rap que
l'agriculture ne pouvait être sauvé que
grâce au marché commun agricole pourquoi
parce que le marché commun agricole
c'est la certitude pour le paysan
français de vendre à meilleur prix est
de trouver des débouchés dans des pays
comme l'allemagne et demain comme
l'angleterre et entrera dans le marché
commun si nous on leur a ils sont des
pays industriels qui ont besoin de
produits agricoles
l'europe et la chance la carte
exceptionnelle pour notre agriculture
et voici que maintenant le gouvernement
déclare que
le marché commun n'est pas indispensable
qu'on pourrait s'en passer
c'est faux il n'y a aucune solution de
rechange
il n'y a d'autre solution de rechange
que le malthusianisme la diminution de
la production et par conséquent l'exode
rural la destruction de l'entreprise
familiale il faut sauver le marché
commun il faut que la france retourne à
bruxelles
c'est ce que je ferais si j'étais élu
président de la république s'il marchait
comme agricole disparaît ces huit cent
mille francs en moyenne de pertes par an
pour chaque entreprise agricole
on s'explique dans ces conditions que le
syndicalisme agricole toutes les
confédérations de l'agriculture ils font
pas de politique se soit adressé au
monde agricole en leur disant que le 5
décembre est une étape décisive pour eux
ils ne peuvent pas reconduire le pouvoir
actuel et qu'il faut au contraire
changer le cours des choses et rétablir
au sommet de l'état une volonté
européenne pour le salut de
l'agriculture
mais le salut de l'agriculture s'est en
même temps salut de la france il ne
s'agit pas d'une catégorie spéciale
seulement c'est pour la france la
possibilité d'une exportation et d'un
enrichissement
il ne faut absolument pas que cette
chance soit perdu et pour la sauver
faisons vite très vite
l'europe je reconnais je vais vous
ramener au parcours que nous avons
tracée au plan que vous nous avez
proposé tout à l'heure au début nous
revenons à la famille française alors
supposons que le chef de famille et
trouver du travail qu'ils aient un
emploi il ya tout de même un problème
quotidien problèmes constants ces
problèmes du logement
c'est un problème qui reste cruciale je
dirais même que l'une des tares les plus
graves de la 5e république qui a disposé
et dieu sait qu'elle s'en vante de cette
année de stabilité sans entrave
c'est d'avoir échoué
dans le domaine du logement là où tous
les autres pays modernes ont réussi et
depuis longtemps nous piétinons autour
de 400 mille logements par an encore
faudrait-il déduire les résidences
secondaires de ce chiffre
l'italie construit davantage l'allemagne
construit plus de 600 mille logements
par an non seulement nous construisons
peu mais nous construisons dans une
qualité contestable la moyenne des
logements français comprend trois pièces
trois pieds séduit 5 en allemagne en
hollande
les familles nombreuses ne trouve pas
les possibilités d'un logement décent
les jeunes ménages paient des loyers
extrêmement cher
après avoir fait de longues even
attendant tous les offices du logement
il y a donc la nécessité de tout un
renversement des perspectives
il faut créer des réserves foncières
dans les grandes villes des autoroutes
de dégagement il faut respecter le droit
de propriété
mais il faut aussi lutter contre la
spéculation en modifiant au besoin la
fiscalité
il faut créer des sociétés hypothécaires
indexant les prêts sur la valeur du
logement
bref il faut tout un élan ce qui a été
fait en allemagne peut l'être en france
j'estime que dans un délai très rapide
en changeant les options du budget en
stimulant l'initiative privée
nous pourrions à table nous aussi le
rythme indispensable des six cent mille
logements faire cesser la honte des
taudis des logements vétustes faire
cesser le fait que neuf cent mille
jeunes foyers français sont obligés de
s'entasser dans le même appartement avec
d'autres familles
il ya là non seulement une revendication
mais un appel à la dignité l'homme a le
droit à son doigt
c'est là le sens même de son
indépendance
mais bien entendu si l'état doit faire
un très grand effort pour le logement il
faut que les français acceptent de le
faire il faut qu'ils acceptent de payer
comme le font les autres peuples
modernes un loyer juste mais raisonnable
et il faut qu'il reprenne goût à l'
épargne en garantissant que cette
épargne ne sera pas perdue dans des
dévaluations
il faut donner la désindexation des
garanties pour l'épargnant nous ne
pouvons pas rester par conséquent dans
la situation actuelle il y a tout un
effort nouveaux efforts de l'état et
fort des français pour leur donner la
dignité du logement est alors la fée du
logis la femme la femme prend une
importance de plus en plus grande dans
la société et la droit et là qu'hier et
je m'en réjouis de plus en plus
l'égalité et tout ce qui peut assurer sa
libération doit être accompli la fée du
logis
c'est notamment le cas de la mère de
famille qui doit travailler au dehors
avoir une profession une femme français
sur deux travaille en dehors de sa
maison bien ces femmes là font 80 heures
par semaine de travail il faut les aider
comment est bien par l'organisation
sociale de l'aide ménagère
cela veut dire des crèches des garderies
d'enfants des écoles maternelles des
mouvements qui doivent être libres
sportives culturelles pour s'occuper des
enfants pendant que le mari et la femme
sont à leurs obligations
professionnelles
cela veut dire l'aménagement du temps de
travail
la journée continue l'étalement des
vacances je ne peux en quelques secondes
traiter au fond tous ces problèmes mais
ils sont dans ma préoccupation car le
rôle de la femme sera de plus en plus
déterminant dans la société moderne
le temps s'écoule monsieur lequel est
alors je vous ramène à l'ordre
chronologique les personnes âgées les
personnes âgées
c'est le problème où l'émotion française
doit être la plus forte
c'est le problème de la solidarité la
solidarité elle doit s'exercer envers
tous ceux qui sont dans la souffrance ou
qui sont dans la reconnaissance du coeur
des français c'est le cas des anciens
combattants qui doivent être honorés des
rapatriés d'algérie qui doivent obtenir
une juste indemnisation et c'est bien
entendu le cas de tous ceux qui ont
travaillé qui arrive au soir de leur vie
il faut distinguer plusieurs aspects
avant d'être tout à fait vieux quand on
arrive à ce qu'on appelle l'âge mûr il
faut trouver pour ce troisième âge des
activités moins fatigante que celle que
peut assumer un homme jeune d activité
conforme à l'expérience d'une personne
qui a pris de l'âge il faut pas laisser
ces gens en dehors du travail
et puis il ya les ressources hélas la
situation reste cruel sur 7 millions de
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans 850
villes doivent se contenter de quatre
francs 65 pages 2 millions 250 mille de
huit nouveaux francs par ch roule à 3
millions de personnes âgées qui sont
pratiquement osons dire des indigents il
faut leur apporter rapidement la justice
et la dignité
il faut dans une première étape
l'ordonné les trois quarts du smig est
très rapidement la valeur du salaire
minimum interprofessionnel garanti
puisque je parle des ressources des
personnes âgées
pensez aux cadres qui sont menacés de
perdre leur autonomie leur qu'est ce que
l'état voudrait être utilisée pour ses
besoins je m'oppose formellement à cette
manière de voir l'autonomie des thèses
des cadres doit subsister entièrement
il faut aussi penser à l'hébergement des
personnes âgées lorsqu'elles n'ont plus
de famille assez de ces auspices au
dortoir vétustes et surpeuplées très
long comme je les ai vus dans certaines
villes comme à toulouse notamment des
foyers qui permettent de donner à la
personne âgée sa liberté son autonomie
d'existence et les facilités d'une vie
communautaire
voilà l'ensemble des grands problèmes
qui sont devant nous tout dépend
finalement d'un choix politique
il suffit de changer légèrement le taux
de progression de l'économie de 2 et
demi pour cent pour avoir 12 100
milliards de plus qu'ils nous donneront
soit cent mille places supplémentaires
260 mille logements ou deux cent mille
lits dans les hôpitaux qui nous font
tant défaut
il suffit d'un choix politique d'autres
priorités pour tout changer puisse le 5
décembre le pays
passer de ses besoins à l'espérance que
nous courons ensemble les satisfaire
dans la dignité